the shipping bottleneck continues as joe
biden ignores reality and blames private
companies inflation spikes while the
white house down plays the problem and
hunter biden's email scandal starts to
infect joe i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by
expressivevpn protect your data from
bigtech with the vpn i trust visit
expressvpn.com we'll get to all the news
in just one moment first let me just
remind you that if you are using the
internet without a vpn that is sort of
like saying your credit card number out
loud in a very crowded place while on
your cell phone it is pretty much the
dumbest thing that you can do you should
be using a vpn to protect your data
because pretty much everything important
you are doing in life you're doing on
the internet these days believe it or
not isps know every single website you
visit then those isps can sell that
information to ad companies and tech
giants who use the data to target you
but you shouldn't just use any vpn you
find you really need to be using express
vpn because expressvpn reroutes your
network data through a secure encrypted
tunnel so your isp can't see or sell
your online activity it is simple to use
fire up the app click one button
expressvpn is rated number one by both
cnet and techradar it works on phones
laptops even routers so everyone who
shares your wi-fi can be protected i use
expressvpn on all of my devices because
frankly my data is none of anybody
else's business protect your online
privacy today by visiting expressvpn.com
ben today that's expr essvpn.com
ben you can get an extra three months
for free when you use expressvpn.com
ben today well the biden
administration's economic woes continue
they are very very dire at this point
because it is patently obvious that
inflation is no longer a temporary
phenomenon it is a near permanent
phenomenon according to the new york
times today consumer prices jumped more
than expected last month with rent food
and furniture costs surging as a limited
supply of housing and a shortage of
goods stemming from supply chain
troubles combined to fuel rapid
inflation this consumer price index
claimed 5.4 in september from a year
earlier that's faster than its 5.3
percent increase through august that is
above economist forecasts monthly price
gains also exceeded predictions with the
index rising 0.4 from august to
september
the figures raised the stakes for both
the federal reserve and the white house
which are facing a longer period of
rapid inflation than they had expected
and may soon come under pressure to act
to ensure the price gains don't become a
permanent fixture which means you would
assume that the federal reserve is going
to have to taper faster than they said
they were going to have to taper they're
gonna have to stop buying bonds they're
gonna have to lower the overnight
interest rates they're gonna have to do
all the things that you normally do in
order to tamp down inflation which
typically results in slower growth at
least in the moment because they have
now created a stagflation situation in
which economic growth is not proceeding
as fast as it was supposed to and we
also have inflation and the only way to
cure that we know from the paul volcker
days is to cut down on the inflation and
then wait for the economy to catch up on
wednesday president biden said his
administration was doing what it could
to fix supply chain problems that have
helped to produce shortages long
delivery times and rapid price increases
for food tv automobiles and other
products
in remarks at the white house biden said
the port of los angeles would begin
operating around the clock to relieve
growing backlogs and that the
administration was encouraging states to
license truck drivers more quickly
companies including walmart fedex and
ups are also moving to work more
off-peak hours according to president
biden we'll get to his shipping policy
in just one second quick note on that
remember that time that secretary of
transportation pete booty judge was the
greatest secretary of transportation of
all time and he was very focused on
equity in the roads and transportation
was all about equity and of course
secretary of booty judge was
appointed to that position because he
thinks that transportation is deeply
romantic and he has a long record of not
fixing potholes in south bend indiana
well you might have thought that maybe
he might have spent the last few months
you know boning up on exactly how ports
work apparently not so instead we get a
shipping bottleneck the likes of which
we simply have not seen in our lifetimes
we'll get to that in a moment
there are serious downstream
consequences to the sort of inflation
that we are seeing so for example social
security is pegged to inflation right is
price adjusted that means that social
security benefits are gonna rise six
percent in 2022 that is the most in four
decades gets who gets to pay for that
you get to pay for that isn't that
exciting benefits from social security
according to the new york times which
tens of millions of retired americans
rely on to pay their bills will increase
by 5.9 in 2022 according to the social
security administration it's the biggest
boost in 40 years as prices for food
cars and rent keep climbing
the increase is known as a cost of
living adjustment it's the largest since
1982 when that adjustment was 7.4
according to data from the
administration the average benefit would
climb to almost 1700 a month
the adjustment is a response to consumer
prices in the united states that have
jumped at their fastest pace in years
and all of this means that hourly wages
are down so for all of the talk about
from democrats well look at how much
leverage workers have they're not coming
back because they have so much leverage
because there's so many open jobs and
isn't that great well there's only one
problem if the idea is that workers are
getting better wages and better working
conditions because they are holding out
what if all of that is outweighed by the
fact they are also paying higher prices
see the economy has consumers and also
producers and they are the same people
right you are both a consumer and a
producer in the economy so if you don't
produce but you do consume it turns out
that there will be bottlenecks there
will be shortages there will be
inflation and your failure to work is
going to end up hurting you and then
even when you go back to work the prices
are going to outrank
exactly how much you've increased your
pay that's exactly what's happening
right now according to the wall street
journal editorial board is inflation
still transitory as the federal reserve
and white house like to say not if
you've been visiting the grocery store
gas pump online retailer or anywhere
else across the us economy and not
judging by wednesday's report on
consumer prices for september which
showed the same rapid rate of inflation
that has been apparent all this year
this is the largest year-over-year
increase since 2008 in inflation and and
the details in the report add to the
evidence inflation is likely to be
persistent remember when used car prices
popped in the spring and various
progressive sages said inflation would
vanish when those prices stopped rising
well in september used car and truck
prices fell 0.7 but the increase in the
cost of the other goods and services
more than made up the difference used
price vehicles are still up 24.4 in the
last 12 months by the way the price of
new vehicles rose 1.3 and are up 8.7
for the year try renting a car or truck
and assuming you can find one you'll pay
about 43 more than you did in september
2020.
beef prices are up 17.6 over the last
year fresh fish and seafood are 10.7
percent higher major appliances are
nearly 10 more expensive furniture and
betting are up 11.2 percent
and the september report includes omens
of future inflation notably the rise in
housing costs actual rents rose 0.5
percent for the month while owner
equivalent rents rose at 0.4 percent
the latter is especially important
because it makes makes up nearly a
quarter of the consumer price index and
the increase in housing costs show up in
equivalent owner rents with a lag
housing costs have been soaring but the
case shiller index up nearly 20 in a
year as of july that increase will flow
into the consumer price index as of next
year
inflation is a monetary phenomenon and
there's no question the fed has been
pursuing one of the most radical
monetary experiments in history since
april 2020 by basically just paying
everybody to stay home and making credit
free
the breadth of the goods and asset price
increases suggests a monetary cause pick
a financial asset or material commodity
as prices climb real estate is booming a
plot in johnson county iowa recently
sold for 26 thousand dollars an acre
so much money is chasing assets that
smart or manipulative folks have been
inventing assets like non-fungible
tokens for investment some of which
don't actually have any openly and
obviously tangible value there's a
reason the bitcoin has been rising over
the course of the last couple of years
all this is good news for asset holders
but workers are paying the price and
here is the key for the manufacturing
base that joe biden needs to win in 2024
and democrats need to hold in 2022.
real average hourly earnings rose 0.2 in
september they are down 0.8 since a year
ago
real hourly earnings are down 1.9 since
january when joe biden became president
the white house knows this has become a
political problem which is why is it
it's ignoring inflation and instead
focusing on its frantic bladed efforts
to fix supply chain bottlenecks
if they really want to help with supply
they need to forego forego their plan
tax and regulatory increase on producers
so inflation is a problem you got supply
chain bottlenecks that are a problem and
the administration's strategy here is
basically to downplay the entire problem
we'll get some more on this in just one
second first
let me tell you about security so i am
big on security okay we spend a lot of
money at this company on security as
somebody in the public eye with a
business that has over 100 employees
security is of utmost importance we've
got death threats we've got violent
protesters pretty i've seen pretty much
all of these things
as you know if you've watched even five
minutes of the news in the last year
criminals have become more and more
aggressive from new york to los angeles
business owners are feeling the effects
of the defund the police movement in
fact i was just texting with a friend in
los angeles yesterday and he was saying
that he have he has friends who are
being literally just held up at gunpoint
while driving down the street in
downtown los angeles thanks in part to
diminishing our police force it's never
been more important to protect the
people in assets essential to you so if
you're a business owner looking to beef
up your security or you're in need of a
comprehensive risk assessment i suggest
you follow the daily wires lead and go
with fortified risk group these are the
people that i work with i literally
trust them with my life and the lives of
my family members these guys are former
navy seals with over 35 years of
experience in international domestic
public and private security services the
daily wire trusts them with our safety i
trust them with my safety and with my
kids safety so can't get a better
recommendation than that go check them
out right now at fortifiedrisk.com
get a risk assessment that is battle
tested fortified risk dot com again
that's fortified risk.com go check them
out right now and protect yourself the
same way that i do on a personal
security level do it for your business
do it for your family fortifiedrisk.com
all right so the white house continues
to downplay inflation even though it
obviously is a serious problem
patrice onwuka is the director of the
center for economic opportunity at the
independent women's forum she writes for
the washington post dollar tree recently
announced that higher freight costs won
elements in rising inflation affecting
consumer prices nationwide are forcing
the company to abandon its just a buck
policy dollar tree has already been
testing prices up to five dollars at its
plus and combo stores it resisted
pressure from investors in recent years
to ditch the dollar barrier in its
traditional stores
but now they've gotten rid of those
and the fact is that people are paying
the price a demographic profile of
dollar tree customers reveals discount
store shoppers skew older in the 45 to
64 age range and tend to be black not
surprisingly people in those groups fall
in the lowest income brackets below 60
000 annual income and are less likely to
be college educated
dollar tree's announcement of its policy
change suggests policy prices could hit
a buck 25 to a buck 50 which might not
sound like much but if you are spending
your last 10 or 15 bucks a month on
necessities that could be the entire
margin
in every inflationary period these the
elderly are especially vulnerable
because their savings are going down
right as you devalue the dollar people
who have money in the bank that money
becomes worthless
it's a tax on people who save inflation
it's also a tax on hourly wage earners
so the people who are getting hurt the
worst by the democratic blow money
through the door policy are exactly the
people democrats are supposedly standing
up for so the white house has to
downplay all this shinsaki over the
white house she spent the day yesterday
downplaying the inflation and gas prices
we are very well aware um for a range of
issues and we should talk about those
that the american people are of course
impacted by
rising prices of gas in some parts of
the country not all
and also
looking ahead to the winter season and
looking at
natural gas supply out there maybe they
don't look at it exactly through that
prism but i would say we do
okay and then she continued along these
lines she was at being asked about
inflation
and she makes the utterly asinine and
disconnected statement that people are
not comparing prices to a year or two
years ago so she doesn't care about the
inflation statistics
um let me just say you know what people
do care about they care about whether
their prices have inflated over time and
how much of their money they're spending
and whether their real hourly wages are
going down or up like that stuff does
matter to humans nazi genesaki of course
because she's a keyboard warrior right
she spent her entire career in the warm
comforting arms of a government that
pays for salary or in a cnn air
conditioned studio
and she's lucky i know she's lucky
because i have a very similar job i'm
lucky
but for all those people out there who
may be working on the margins right
people who are who are working hard
scrabble blue collar jobs
or frankly people who just aren't making
all that much money no matter what their
job is you think that inflation doesn't
matter to them people who are struggling
to get by who have a lot of bills
jen's hockey downplaying this thing just
demonstrates how out of touch the elite
democrats are
we all understand the american people
are not looking at cost to cost
comparisons from this year to two years
ago they're looking at cost to cost
comparisons to their checkbooks from
eight months ago or 12 months ago and
even though factually if you look back
to two years ago things may be
comparative that's not how people look
at things so our objective here is to
tackle each of these issues uh with the
approach that we think will help address
it in the shortest term tell us how tell
us jen saki how people look at things
how people look at things they don't
look at their prices they just look at
whether we are democrats and then they
decide they love us it's like nancy
pelosi yesterday saying that even if
people don't know what's in the bill
they love the bill
that's not how you you don't gauge
public opinion that way and democrats
are about to find out quite hard in 2022
that the american public does not assess
these issues the way that professional
politicos like gensaki assess these
issues
meanwhile one of the reasons that you
are seeing price increases is not just
the monetary phenomenon that has been
created by the federal reserve over the
course of the last two years and the joe
biden plan to spend more money than god
has ever seen but also the problem with
the pores right so we have these
shipping bottlenecks
so
let's talk a little bit about what
exactly is happening with the shipping
bottlenecks and why we have these
shipping bottlenecks so dominic pino who
writes for national review had a good
piece in late september talking about
this
he says first shipping is a global
industry but this crisis is largely an
american problem according to the 2020
world bank his market container port
performance index for example not one
u.s port ranked in the top 50 global
port in terms of getting a ship in and
out of port according to scott lincecum
who writes for the dispatch the highest
ranked at u.s port statistically was
philadelphia at 83 with virginia close
behind at 85 and new york new jersey at
89. oakland ranks 332nd
la long beach ranked a dismal 328 and
333 respectively so why are our ports so
far behind not because we don't spend on
infrastructure as the byte
administration would have you believe
the federal government could spend a
quadrillion dollars on ports it wouldn't
change the contracts with longshoremen
unions that prevent ports from operating
24 7 as they do in asia and send labor
costs through the roof
according to scott lindsecum union dock
workers on the west coast are making an
average an average
stock workers okay of 171 thousand
dollars a year
plus free health care
pretty sweet gig
and when you sign a crappy union
contract
on behalf of the port of los angeles
which is a government agency when you do
that sort of thing
what you end up doing is incentivizing
less work it turns out that rich union
contracts just like everywhere else in
the american economy tend to stagnate
whoever the employer is and make it less
effective
all the folks on the left are big into
unions ah unions are the bulwark of the
middle class well it turns out the union
contracts are very good for the people
who are members of the union and have
jobs and for everyone else there are
serious externalities and the ports are
one of those casualties
the unions have been fighting automation
at american force for a long time
because they're afraid that they're
simply going to be replaced by machines
also according to this columnist for
national review dominique pino
the pandemic is not the primary cause of
the crisis the pandemic merely
imminentized a crisis that was long
brewing
much of the current mess in the united
states was decades in the making
reflecting systemic labor and trade
policies that decreased the efficiency
and flexibility u.s ports and the
economy reliant on them enjoy in the
best of times and desperately need in
the worst
the problems we are
enduring now will not be solved by a
pandemic emergency stopgap measure they
require real changes to the way the
industry works that will be difficult to
design and implement and will encounter
heavy resistance from interest groups
that benefit from the status quo
okay so we've got real systemic problems
in the shipping industry they are
brought about by really bad trade policy
and really bad union policy
and
all of this is not fixable by joe biden
saying words
see the way that shipping works
as pina wrote back in june
is is pretty complex
like he points out that the global
shipping industry is still behind from
the pandemic and likely will be for
quite some time that is because
cancer there there have been cancer
cancelled sailings and ships only like
to ship when they are
the owners of the ships only like to
ship when the ship is completely full
because it takes like three weeks to
send a ship from asia to los angeles
it's not like a plane
if you have a cargo ship sitting in la
that's scheduled for shanghai and the
shipping line decides to cancel the
sailing
that stinks for both the people trying
to ship things out of la and for people
trying to receive things in shanghai
but it also stinks for people trying to
ship things out of shanghai because the
people running the shanghai port were
planning on using that same boat
they were planning on being in shanghai
in three weeks now it won't be there so
you got three books worth of containers
that pile up on the docks of shanghai so
you might think they can wait for the
next one but every boat is scheduled to
be full so you end up with these giant
backlogs
so
all of this is a serious problem we have
a serious shortage of longshoremen in
the united states there aren't enough
workers to unload them
and also import volume from china the
ocean shipping is up 54 year-over-year
exports have only ticked up by 4.4 so a
lot of containers are leaving asia but
not enough have actually been returning
there
and you need those containers in order
to ship things
so not enough ships they're not enough
containers to move more goods than ever
before not enough workers to load and
unload them and that is going to drive
up the prices so joe biden's silly silly
plan here is that he's going to order
the ports to stay open for 24 hours
we'll get to why this is a silly plan in
just one second first let us talk about
a simple fact that is that hackers bad
guys that are decent in crime right i
mean this is literally how they make
their living
well if they can steal you know property
from you like physical property from you
how about all of those assets that are
not material right don't they don't
exist just in a safe at your house
you know the social security
administration computer servers are 45
years old computer services at health
and human services are 50. maybe that's
how cyber criminals hacked u.s census
bureau's computers where everything
about you is stored the threat of a
cyber thief stealing your credit card
that's actually not your biggest risk on
a personal level the biggest risk is
that somebody fakes ownership of your
home this is called home title theft the
fbi calls it one of the fastest growing
crimes in america
cyber criminals simply hack into
vulnerable government bank or mortgage
company servers where copies of your
home title is stored they forge your
signature saying you sold your home to
them and then borrow on your home and
leave you in debt you're not going to
know until the collection notices show
up so go ahead and protect your most
valuable asset today go to
hometitlelock.com register your address
see if you're already a victim and use
promo code radio for 30 free days of
protection again that is home title lock
dot com promo code radio home title lock
dot com okay so the shipping shortages
that are happening are not
only joe biden's fault but they are
certainly partly joe biden's fault
because
as it turns out when you drive prices up
through inflation and when you sign a
rich union contract
and when you do all of these things
ignoring the realities on the ground
well you end up with some bottlenecks
when you have labor shortages because
people are staying home from work when
you tell people not to go back to work
when you tell people you'll pay them to
stay home and then you have labor
shortages on one end bottlenecks in the
system tend to pile up it's sort of like
how traffic problems happen
if you ever think if you ever think
about a traffic problem you think why
why are why are there traffic jams why
doesn't why don't all the cars keep
moving all it takes studies have shown
is a couple of cars going on an on-ramp
a little bit slower than the rest of
traffic and the downstream effects on a
crowded freeway are pretty dramatic
because people start slowing up behind
and suddenly you have a bottleneck
so joe biden's plan is that he wants to
keep the los angeles port open 24 hours
a day seven days a week he pledged this
would relieve pressure on an overworked
supply chain that has frustrated
americans and blossomed into a major
economic shortcoming
there's only one problem with this plan
it is not going to do anything biden
said that the announcement had the
potential to be a game changer and
unclogging the nation's supply lines so
here was joe biden trying to blame
private companies for the shipping
delays as opposed to you know the bad
policy of the poors
today's announcement has the potential
to be a game changer
i say potential
because all of these goods won't move by
themselves
for the
for the positive impact
to be felt all
all across the country and by all of you
at home
we need major retailers who order the
goods and the freight movers who take
the goods from the ships to factories
and the stores to step up as well
so it's all about the private companies
who aren't picking up their stuff okay
so here is the problem with what joe
biden is saying aside from the fact that
the man is not with us
according to the washington post no
right-wing outlet the extended hours the
administration is touting represent
something less than the full
around-the-clock operations that are
typical of the world's most advanced
cargo moving facilities and is what
we've been saying our ports in the
united states
are operated idiotically we don't have
the automation we don't have 24 7 we
have longshoreman unions that are being
paid an absolute fortune
the port of long beach which makes up
one half of the nation's chief import
gateway began a pilot program late last
month of late night and pre-dawn work an
administration official said tuesday
long beach had already gone to 24 7 and
la would be meeting that effort but
here's the thing that's a lie only one
of long beach ports six container
terminals works 24 hours a day one out
of six it only does so monday through
thursday so it's not 24 7. biden said
the l.a port would be open for 60
additional hours each week but phillip
stanfield port spokesman said he
couldn't say how many la terminals will
now begin operating around the clock
gene soroka executive director of the la
port said on twitter operational details
are being discussed and worked out with
supply chain stakeholders
some industry executives described the
administration's latest initiative which
the white house built as nearly doubling
the port's cargo handling hours as
incomplete
matt trapp chief executive of the harbor
trucking association whose members
service the ports said the measure will
make a big difference only if terminals
abandon requirements for truckers to
return a specific type of empty shipping
container before collecting a full one
the problem with that of course is that
if you don't actually have the empty
shipping containers that are being
returned to the port then those ships
can't leave so they should stay there
and craig grosskart senior vice
president for global ocean at ceco
logistics said quote it will accomplish
zero it's just window dressing indeed
the administration said an additional 3
500 containers each week would move
through the la port during the new
nighttime hours thanks to promises from
walmart fedex ups target home depot and
samsung
the port expects to process
almost 80 000 containers this week
so in other words this is a minute
upgrade from what was already being
shipped in
the administration says giant companies
will set an example that will spur
others to follow but longer working
hours at the neighboring ports which
operate as a single complex under dual
management will only matter if trains
trucks and warehouses all do the same
and truckers are reluctant to show up at
the long beach port from three to seven
am
because they have nowhere to take
containers at that hour nothing's open
okay so
basically joe biden is trying to slap a
tiny tiny band-aid on a giant problem
that in the end is created by
macroeconomic conditions that have been
generated by the federal reserve and his
work policies and bad union contracts
and failure for years to upgrade the the
port contracts and how these things work
it turns out that bad policy has long ta
they have long tails long downstream bad
effects we'll get some more on this in
just one second first
right now is an excellent time to
refinance your home it really is like a
great time because the rates are not
going to remain this low forever like
we're going to talk about the fed
tapering in just a second the fact is
that we are going to start seeing
mortgage rates increase sometime in the
next few months now is an excellent time
to refine your mortgage if you have not
already done so mortgage rates are lower
than ever which means you could easily
drop your rate and monthly payment all
you have to do is call american
financing america's home for home loans
take advantage of a free mortgage review
that's right free meaning no pressure no
obligation no upfront or hidden fees
just a simple conversation with a salary
based mortgage consultant someone is
going to listen to and guide you so
you're getting a custom loan that
achieves all of your goals from lower
rates to shorter terms even debt
consolidation they've got you covered so
don't put off a refinance any longer
there are still options in the twos they
cannot stay this low forever pre-qualify
for free by calling
866-721-3300 that's
or visit 866-721-3300
that's americanfinancing.net and mls one
eight two three three four nmls consumer
access dot org again check them out
americanfinancing.net never has been a
better time to refinance go check them
out right now
americanfinancing.net okay so as we say
the 24 7 talk by joe biden it really
means nothing
according to the wall street journal
back on september 30 quote a pilot
program offering 24-hour container
operations at the port of long beach
hasn't attracted any truckers any
more than two weeks since the extended
hours began highlighting challenges
facing southern california seaports as
dozens of ships back up off the coast
total terminals international llc among
the largest terminals of long beach
began september 13th to allow truckers
to pick up containers between 3 and 7
a.m monday to thursday
so far we've had zero deliveries tti
chief executive bill parrott said
parrot said tti is talking to local
trucking companies to see if the
terminal can attract drivers to pick up
and drop off boxes
the extended hours are among efforts at
the neighboring la and long beach ports
to cope with a flood of imports this
year that has swamped the critical us
trade gateway and snarled inland supply
chains the backups have led to a record
number of container ships idling
offshore for up to three weeks for birth
space
an armada that peaked at 73 ships on
september 19th and counted 64 vessels as
of the end of september
the congestion is exacerbating soaring
costs and shipping delays for us
manufacturers and retailers all across
the country most terminals are closed at
least several hours a day during the
week with more limited operations on
saturdays and sundays the shift to 24 op
24-hour operations at one of long beach
port's six terminals was encouraged by
the biden administration but it really
hasn't done anything
mario cordov cordero the executive
director of the port of long beach and
proponents of 24 hour operations says
the port has asked major retailers to
direct truckers to use overnight gates
but it will take time to set up new work
patterns we need their buy-in so they
can direct their drayage companies to
move this cargo
jonathan gold vice president for supply
chain at the national retail federation
said retailers have concerns about the
program's restrictions as well as a
nationwide shortage of the truck chassis
that are used to transport seat
containers
dragged companies which specialize in
hauling cargo by truck from ports to
local yards and distribution facilities
say the overnight system is burdensome
truckers can only make an appointment to
pick up a container if they're able to
drop off a specific type of container
and chassis during the same run getting
everything to match up can be difficult
said matt trapp chief executive of the
harbor trucking association schrapp said
i commend tti for what they're trying to
do but if you can't get the appointment
in the first place because it doesn't
line up it doesn't make any difference
harrod said that the terminal accepts
containers from seven ocean carriers but
truckers are limited by the type of
chassis they're actually able to drop
off
so this whole thing is a mess you know
who could have helped with this maybe
pete buda judge but pete booty judge was
too busy speaking of the romance of
airports talking about how he likes choo
choo trains here's pete booty judge
announcing that we are seeing challenges
yes we've noticed
how bad are they going to get for
americans and i'm talking specifically
you know leading here into the december
holidays where people are relying on
getting goods on getting presents
well i think there's always been two
kinds of christmas shoppers there's the
ones who have all their list completed
by halloween and then there's people
like me who show up at the mall on
christmas eve if you're in that ladder
bucket uh obviously there's going to be
more challenges
it's so exciting by the way people judge
according to internal democratic polling
is like the number two shot to replace
joe biden behind kamala harris wha what
a world of joy they have over there in
the democratic party meanwhile the white
house is saying you know we we can't
give you any answers as to the supply
chain crisis and how that's going to
affect christmas we're only the white
house right so uh we we're not we're not
ups or the postal service or that i mean
i noticed the postal service is part of
the federal government but here's
shinsaki
can
this administration guarantee
that holiday packages will arrive on
time
we are not the postal service or ups or
fedex we cannot guarantee what we can do
is use every lever at the federal
government disposal to reduce uh delays
to ensure that we are
addressing bottlenecks in the system
including uh ports and the the need for
them to be open longer hours so that
goods can arrive uh and we can continue
to press uh not only uh workers and
unions but also companies to take as
many steps as they can to reduce these
delays okay except that this is a
complicated process and you guys can't
just flip a switch and then suddenly
open this stuff up not unless you're
willing to go to war with the
longshoremen's union so it'll be
interesting to see if the biden
administration is indeed willing to go
to war with its union constituents over
the port
because this is one area where the
united states has really been lacking
for a very long time and i guarantee you
the people who've been signing the
contract with those union workers i
promise you they all work for the
democratic party meanwhile the good news
is that joe biden continues to not be
with us so joe biden did this little
presser yesterday he got tongue-tied
trying to say supply chains that was
great
the commitments being made today
are a sign of major progress in moving
goods from manufacturers to a store or
to your front door
i want to thank my supply chain
disruption task force which we set up in
june
and well you know his supply saying
that's good and then afterward could he
answer any questions no he could not he
was just going to jet out of there or
hobble out of there as the case may be
may god protect our troops thank you all
so very much
back to the basement
matlock rerun is on
gotta get some pudding in there
and sure the insurer calls him
meanwhile the fed is talking about
tapering
so
if you've thought that the economy uh
was going to be a problem for joe biden
it is going to get a lot worse because
the fact is that when the fed tapers
you're going to start seeing spending
drawbacks right so that's going to tamp
down on inflation i mean the fed should
never have been pursuing monetary policy
that's loose in the first place but when
they start tapering get ready for the
world of hurt to descend on the biden
administration
according to the wall street journal
federal reserve officials last month
worried that disrupted supply chains
were raising the risks of more
persistent inflation as they firmed up
plans to reduce their bond buying
stimulus program next month and
concluded by the middle of next year
under plans discussed last month the fed
would reduce its purchases by 15 billion
a month divided proportionally between
treasury and mortgage bonds officials
discussed starting the taper in
mid-november if they follow the schedule
penciled out last month purchases would
conclude by june that schedule for
phasing out the fed's stimulus program
is somewhat faster than investors had
anticipated just a few months ago
officials don't want to be in a position
where they feel compelled to raise rates
at a time when they are still fueling
monetary stimulus by purchasing assets
so
great
everything is going great the the biden
economy is booming guys everything is
fine and you know what really solved
this is if they spent more money
probably if they spent more money on
something that would solve it and also
if they they continued the paranoia
about kova that'd probably solve it as
well
solve your labor shortages by covered
paranoia and solve inflation by blowing
out the spending probably this will all
work it'll be great get some more of
this in just one second okay right now
if you are a business owner the fact is
that you probably have some open jobs
because there are 10.4 million of them
in the united states and it's hard to
find the best employees frankly at this
point it's kind of hard to find
employees at all what if you had a
service that helped you do this and do
so in excellent fashion this is what zip
recruiter does
they use a process called invite to
apply it gives you as the hiring manager
the power to pick your favorites from
top candidates and right now you can try
invite to apply for free at
ziprecruit.com dailywire so how does
invite to apply work well when you post
a job on zip recruiter they send you the
most qualified people for your job then
you can easily review the candidates and
invite your top choices to apply for
your job lauren webb svp of talent
acquisition for mendula health raves
about zip recruit's invite to apply she
says i love that feature because we have
a much higher follow-through rate if i
invite candidates it's easy for me it's
easy for them in fact according to zip
recruiter internal data jobs where
employers use zip recruiters invite to
apply get on average two and a half
times more candidates which helps make
for a faster hiring process so if you're
a business in need of great employees
head on over to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r to try
ziprecruiter for free that
ziprecruiter.com slash daily wire zipper
crew is indeed the smartest way to hire
all right i'll get to more on all of
this in just one second first not only
did we have an awesome showing of
backstage at the ryman this past tuesday
we also dropped some awesome news the
daily wire has a bunch of new projects
in the works that are going to change
the way you stream because we are
bringing you even more non-woke content
that you literally will not be able to
find anywhere else i'm pleased to
announce we have now officially dropped
the teaser trailer for shut-in this is
daily wire's first original production
the film which is just it's a tight
awesome tense thriller it follows a
young mother who's barricaded inside a
pantry by her violent ex-boyfriend she
has to use her ingenuity to protect her
two small children from escalating
danger while finding an escape route it
really is it's pretty riveting stuff
here's a 60-second look into a thriller
you're not going to want to miss
laney
i told you i need to see you at all
times do you understand me
well i'm gonna take off tonight so the
kids can sleep most of the way well i'm
mostly done i just need to finish
cleaning out the pantry
[Music]
lady
mommy someone's here
[Music]
get away from him
please let me out
oh my god
[Music]
yeah that's a real movie right there and
let me tell the performances are great
it looks great and man it is tense we
also want to share a message with you
from the fearless gina carano about her
new daily wire movie terror on the
prairie we just started production this
week take a look
hi daily wire members this is gina
carano i'm coming to you
from the set of terror on the prairie um
we came up to montana
and it is absolutely god's country we're
making new friends
we've attracted the most incredible cast
and crew and a hell of a director we're
gonna make a great
great movie um i'm in love with the
script i'm in love with the character
i'm living fantasy right now so um
i can't wait for you guys to see it
we're gonna work hard
after we announced our first project
this summer the hollywood union started
debating vaccine mandates forecast and
crew and i wasn't into that i don't
believe anybody gets to make your
medical choices for you and i'm not
willing to force maths and vaccines on
anyone else
thank you to all the daywire members you
guys have been an extended family uh
thank you to you know everybody for
making this possible without you i
i don't know where i'd be right now and
right now there's no other place i'd
rather be so
i hope everybody is doing well um keep
fighting
stick together we got this never give up
and how do you how do you not love gina
i mean that gina is just the best this
is all coming to the daily wire in 2022
so there's no better time to join us
than right now head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe enter code 2022
for 25 off your membership that's
dailywire.com
subscribe code2022
for 25 off a new daily wire membership
and stay tuned we have a lot more
updates and new content coming you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
meanwhile the democrats continue to talk
about blowing out the spending
representative framilla jayapal who's
become sort of the voice of the squad
when it comes to spending because she
doesn't sound quite as crazy as aoc or
ayanna presley or any of the other
members of the squad she's out there
basically holding joe biden's feeds of
the fire
saying we want as much spending as
humanly possible here she was on msnbc
yesterday
there are two people that still need to
come on board and the president is in
many ways in my view the best person to
be talking to them the real negotiation
here is with the president because this
is the president's agenda this isn't
some
you know agenda of 10 senators that was
developed separate from everyone else no
this is the president's agenda so i
think it's completely appropriate that
those two hold out senators would talk
to the president about what they believe
okay so she is attempting to hold the
democrats feats of the fire on the left
the same thing from bernie sanders right
so the democrats have been trying to get
mansion and cinema to move
and they've not done a great job getting
the progressives to move and yet they're
still claiming they're not in disarray
so good luck to them here's
representative on that
for us we've been very clear that 98 of
all democrats agreed so this idea that
somehow democrats are in disarray and
there's terrible disagreement it's not
true we're waiting for two people to
tell us what they agree on first of all
because they don't agree with each other
and then we'd like them to tell us what
they want us to consider that is
different
from the act that is on the table that
the president agrees with that 98
percent of democrats agree with that 70
percent of the american people agree
with if they know what's in it okay it's
gonna be fascinating to see how this
plays out frankly because mansion and
cinema have basically no incentive to
make a deal with people like pramila
jayapal if you are a if you are a
senator from arizona in a very purple
state or from a very red state like joe
manchin is and you are seen as having
signed off on a big spending plan what
is the upside for you exactly especially
in the midst of a bad economic turn here
what exactly is the upside
and meanwhile if you're promising or
bernie sanders what's the upside for you
in sending off on a fairly
moderate spending plan according to you
none of this stuff is moderate spending
trillions of dollars i mean these these
numbers are insane
okay but it's gonna be hard for
democrats to bridge this gap if they
finally do bridge the gap i'm not sure
they get much of a win out of any of it
and yet this is what they're spending
their time on and the american people
are like you guys are arguing amongst
yourself over how much money we should
spend when we are literally earning less
month on month than we were the month
before thanks to inflation
and you're telling us that we can't go
back to work
this is policy that is designed to make
life worse for americans and democrats
are going to pay the price for this they
really really are speaking of which the
utter discombobulation of the of the
administration's coveted policies the
other half of all of this
and we have always said from the
beginning of this pandemic that public
health experts have one job and one job
only right which is to try to minimize
the amount of death that happens the
amount of health damage that happens in
a particular society but public health
experts are appointees they are not
political officials it is the job of
political officials to balance all of
the interests this is true in all public
policy literally all of it there's not a
single public policy that does not have
costs and benefits
there are public policy costs to setting
a speed limit at a particular speed if
you slowed every everybody down to 30
miles an hour there would be many many
fewer
deaths on the roads however you would
also ding the economy by a pretty
significant margin
so we make that public policy trade-off
when it comes to covid the same has been
true since the beginning you were going
to have to decide
what the trade-offs were whether the
trade-offs were worth it what sort of
mitigation measures could be put into
effect and our public health officials
were telling us lies they were telling
us that we could bring the pandemic to
an end and eradicate the disease totally
and this has led the democrats down the
primrose path to hell here so on the one
hand they want to spend as much money as
humanly possible on the other hand they
want to tell you you never have to go
back to work and then they wonder why
stagflation is happening
well finally anthony fauci is coming
around to reality so anthony fauci
yesterday he finally admitted we're not
going to eradicate this disease now
anybody who thinks that anthony thought
she's a hero
you're just crazy and there's this whole
disney plus documentary about fauci and
i have to say the rotten tomatoes
ratings are hilarious it's like 96
positive from the critics two percent
positive from the audience at rotten
tomatoes because people dislike fouchy
people think that fauci shifts his
opinion day-to-day based on what the
administration is telling him which is
true
just a couple of weeks ago he went on
national tv and he said it's not okay if
you even get a breakthrough illness
which of course is very silly now
as the administration starts to realize
that if they actually wish to save
themselves economically speaking they
have to get people back to work they
have to stop with the coveted panic now
you hear about you're trying to walk it
back so here he was yesterday saying
we're actually for all the talk about
how we need to get rid of the disease
it's not going to happen we are seeing
now a decline in acceleration and a
turnaround of cases
where do we ultimately want to be as i
mentioned it is going to be very
difficult at least in the foreseeable
future and maybe ever to truly eliminate
this highly transmissible virus and
again as i mentioned we've only
eradicated one okay so here's my
question then why is all of your policy
talk geared toward eradication if you
talk to anybody who's setting public
policy these days is about eradication
of the virus this is why they're talking
to you about masking your kids up in
schools there's no end point they
literally have no endpoint if there are
zero cases in a school then they say
well it must be because of the masks and
then if you say well okay then when do
we get to remove the masks they say well
never because the virus is still out
there
if you if you say why aren't people
going back to work they'll say well you
never know somebody could get sick
you're like yes but people should go
back to work he said yes but somebody
could get sick
they've created a pathological public
this is what the media and the democrats
have done and dr fauci and our public
health establishment they've created a
pathological fear of a virus that should
not be feared at this point
by pretty much anybody other than people
who are uniquely compromised
immuno-compromised or very very elderly
there is there's no reason to spend
enormous
quantities of brain power worrying about
covid these days now that the vaccines
are available
we are it's over okay if the vaccines
are available and you choose to get a
vaccine you shouldn't be worried if you
choose not to get a vaccine you're
probably not getting vaccinated because
you're not particularly worried
okay so we're done but for a certain
segment of the population
the paranoia has set in and the paranoia
will not leave and so you will get more
mandates you'll get more attempts to
cram down more attempts to control even
though you now have the government
openly admitting you're not going to be
able to eradicate this virus so then
what's the purpose
really what's the purpose of what you're
doing at this point
okay the pathology is visible nearly
everywhere so mark cuban he says that
he's gonna force his employees to be
vaccinated so here he was ranting about
all of this
if you work for me i require my my
employees to be vaccinated um unless
there's a doctor's reason where they
can't be you know like you i don't want
my kids to be at risk so you know the
consequences of you not being vaccinated
is i'm not going to shut the up i'm
going to be in your mother here driving
you mother crazy
what a hero want to hear okay there's
only one problem your kids are not at
risk mark your kids aren't at risk the
total number of children in the united
states who have died over the course of
this pandemic with covet 19 not just
from with is under 600
during that same time total number of
kids who have died from pneumonia closer
to a thousand
according to dr marty mccary from johns
hopkins university total number of kids
total in the united states who have died
from covert 19 without a significant
pre-existing condition is someone who
said this on the show last week is
somewhere between 10 and 20
10 and 20.
and mark cuban is saying that he's going
to yell at you and force you to get
vaccinated be in your mfa year because
his kids are at risk the only way you
can believe this is if you've been
propagandized to democrats have put that
propaganda out there for too long and
now people are ensconced in it and when
they're called on it they have no
response to it
so joe rogan who is i mean listen i'm
full disclosure i'm very friendly with
joe i think joe's great so joe head on
sanjay gupta from cnn their medical
expert over at cnn and it just went so
poorly for gupta because if you are the
public health expert over the last year
you look like a fool you've done a
terrible job generally speaking so gupta
was asked by rogan about children
vaccine and rogan says something very
simple and what you're about to hear is
a very symbological point from rogan
that gupta completely misses hey rogan
says to him
so here's the deal sanjay you're
vaccinated right
and guppy's like yeah he's like and you
don't feel afraid right he's like yeah
he's like you're 51 right he's like yeah
he's like well um your chances of dying
from covet are still higher than that of
a child so why are we supposed to be
worried about kids
should they be worried should they walk
you're not worried should kids who are
at a lower risk than you should their
parents be worried
here is here's rogan just taking gupta
to the woodshed
your attitude that you're not worried
about catching it because you've been
vaccinated and you're a healthy guy that
is the exact same feeling that people
have about vaccinating their children if
they have healthy children and they know
that statistically speaking there's so
few children that have died from covet
well yeah there there are it's like i
think 500 or so
millions and millions and millions of
kids that probably have been exposed
yeah and but you know it's again part of
it is is not defining this in terms of
life and death oh okay well okay okay
but by the way rogan didn't stop there
he also went after gupta because he's on
cnn and he was like um so i took
ivermectin and people kept saying on cnn
that it was worse to warmer and uh you
guys are liars here is here's rogan just
shall lacking up to over it horse
dewormer's not a flattering thing i get
it it's a lie it's a lie on a news
network and it's a lie that's a willing
that's that's a lie that they're
conscious of this is not a mistake yeah
they're unfavorably framing it as
veterinary medicine don't you think that
a lie like that is dangerous on a news
network when you know that they know
they're lying the thing is we're we're
like going so fast like i feel like i'm
missing i'm missing you
that's a problem that your news network
is not lies
well i don't i don't think dude what did
they say they lied what did they say i
was taking horse dewormer
yeah it turns out that our media are
really really bad at their jobs okay but
here's the problem
a lot of people trust that media a lot
of people listening to that media i
don't see how biden pulls out of the
economic talespin i don't i think that
he has created a pathological paranoia
and a significant percentage of the
population i think there are people who
are going to be wearing masks four years
from now five years from now maybe
forever because they've been told that
the masks are protective it's become a
security blanket i think the message of
the last year truly is that for a new
normal to set in does not take very long
at all like at all
i mean you do wonder over the course of
human history there have been some
pretty massive changes in how people
live and you wonder how did people just
accept that how do people just go along
with it and suddenly they were living a
completely different life than they were
like five years ago
and the answer is that the human brain
is quite adaptable people adapt to new
circumstances very quickly that is the
great superpower of humanity we can
adapt to nearly every circumstance it
also means that we can reorient our
brains to really bad ideas incredibly
quickly and start living in line with
those ideas to our own detriment and
it's very hard to shake us from that
after we get to that unless there is
good leadership this is where leadership
comes in in statesmanship unless you
have people who are out there actively
battling these pathologies these mental
pathologies that people now have about
this
this is going to remain for a long time
and joe biden has he helped create the
pathology
he's got a problem the only way the
economy comes back is if joe biden says
to people you are now safe go live your
life
you won't do it
and the only way the economy comes back
is if joe biden says to people you need
to go back to work and get a job and
meanwhile he's trying to pay them to
stay home
none of this is going to be conducive to
a healthy economy or to a healthy
presidency for joe biden i think that
he's locked himself in a box here and he
is like a mime now he's just he's just
pushing at the invisible glass trying to
find a way out
and meanwhile speaking of joe biden ends
up being trapped in a box with somebody
who's not great so joe biden apparently
is now going to become embroiled in the
hunter biden email scandal remember that
time that that was not a story the 100
biden email scandal remember because the
100 email scandal was super was super
stupid it didn't it was dumb like
remember because the new york post
posted it and we weren't allowed to post
it for a month
and all that well it turns out now that
um yeah it gets a lot worse for joe
biden according to the uk daily mail
president biden could become embroiled
in an fbi investigation of hunter
biden's finances experts say as emails
reveal the father and son shared bank
accounts and paid each other's bills
hmm
remember all those emails about 10 for
the big guy and all of that yeah well if
they share bank accounts that gets a lot
more suspicious
emails were covered by dailymail.com
from hunter's abandoned laptop between
hunter and eric schwerin his business
partner at consultancy rosemont seneca
show that schwerin was working on joe's
taxes discussing the father and son
paying each other's household bills and
even fielding requests for a book deal
for the then vice president as well as
managing the donation of joe's senate
papers to the university of delaware
it's unclear why schwerin had this
intimate role in the vp's affairs rather
than government officials in the office
of the vice president
hunters claim that he and his dad shared
a bank account also raised serious
questions whether funds from the alleged
joints account were used for hunter's
may 2018 week-long bender with a
prostitute in a hollywood hotel
last december hunter admitted in a
public statement he was under federal
investigation over his tax affairs
but joe biden wants to look into your
600 transactions with the irs
the rules do not apply to the specials
like joe biden
alrighty coming up a little bit later
today we'll have one additional hour of
content coming up soon the matt wall
show airs at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to
check it out over at dailywire.com i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica crans the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show